Asia during World War two it's 45
minutes Robert Smith Thompson joins us
with his beautiful wife all the way from
sunny South Carolina
professor Thompson received his master's
degree from Harvard and his PhD from
Michigan he is professor of government
and international studies from the
University of South Carolina he is a
former Fulbright lecturer at Beijing
University and he's the author of
several previous novels and currently he
is working on a new study of the origins
of world war one and besides novels he
also has written several books
historical works as well would you
please welcome Robert Smith Thompson
everyone thank you Sam yes some of my
colleagues think their novels and I also
understand this there's another historic
occasion today this is Richard Nixon's
birthday and I didn't realize that I
haven't one more chance to kick him
around but apparently I do ladies and
gentlemen I'm delighted to be here I've
been the archives speaking before on one
occasion you know in an auditorium that
was fairly grim looking as opposed to
this wonderful room and so I'm
absolutely delighted to be with all of
you or as they would say in South
Carolina with y'all and I hope I
pronounced that correctly last month my
wife Judy and our daughter Polly and I
were in New York I didn't want to but we
got in a cab and we went to the Ground
Zero and just before we got there and
that was a tremendous experience and
most tremendous emotional experience
just before we got there a truck with a
long flatbed came out from one of the
side streets carrying a crushed fire
truck I was absolutely horrified at what
I was seeing and I say that because I
think that in a generation past people
who lived in Honolulu for quite some
time after the bombing of Pearl Harbor
must have been equally horrified I think
in some senses these two events are
similar they're both occasions in which
Americans on American
soil or an American territory have been
attacked and if we get toward the end as
we enter at the end of you would like to
discuss any similar any further
similarities between the current war and
America's war in Asia and the Pacific in
world war ii i'd be happy to at least
cast some thoughts my publisher basic
books was kind enough has been kind
enough to put me on a couple of radio
programs of talk shows with National
Public Radio I would like to begin with
sharing some of the comments that have
come to me on these interviews the first
was from a Chinese in Dallas and I had
been trying to explain something of the
origins of the war of World War two in
Asia and which involved the Chinese war
with the Japan and he made the claim
that for Japan it was very simply
Manchuria today China tomorrow and
America the third day this was in Dallas
as I say and my immediate response was
to say I'm sure they wouldn't want to
have taken Dallas this is a reference to
a Chinese forgery called the Tanaka
memorial whereby the chinese tried to
justify their actions by alleging a
japanese plan to conquer the world and
that is one myth i would like to come
back to in a few moments for the comment
naturally and that fact this is going to
be several times was the old question
did franklin delano roosevelt know in
advance of the attack upon Pearl Harbor
thank you I can stop right now
I have looked and looked and looked and
looked at the best I had I have not
found any documentary evidence that he
knew beforehand of the specific attack
upon Pearl Harbor itself there was
plenty else going on but in response to
this immediate question I have no
evidence the best I was saying to
somebody beforehand the best I can get
is that I've seen the allegation that
Churchill passed along to William
Donovan who was the head of the OSS
information about Pearl Harbor and I
found a reference in the archives of the
University of Virginia at one point to
the effect that Donovan was in the Oval
Office at 11 o'clock on the on December
7 1941 I became very very excited put it
away and went to other things then went
back and I realized he was there at 11
o'clock at night I have no proof I don't
I think if you look at the photographs
from FDR the next day delivering the
address to the Congress that shocked
look on his face I I don't think he knew
of this attack specifically at Pearl
Harbor in advance and then out of in
Denver I didn't interview with NPR there
too I had a Japanese so you see I'm
covering all the all the territory here
and I dealt in my book at some length
with the atrocities carried out by the
Japanese in the Japanese gentleman or
should I say the gentleman from Japan
made the statement that there were no
such atrocities he was a Japanese
Holocaust denier there are lots of myths
about world war two in Asia and the
Pacific and I cite these three examples
to show that out of the three major
countries that were involved I suppose
I'm leaving Britain out if I want to say
the three major countries but the
British weren't declining power out of
China Japan and America alike there have
been certain myths that have existed to
this very day and I think each of this
myths each of these myths tries to put
one's own actions in the best possible
light which is of course why we have
myths to justify ourselves I would like
to try to use
today's session to cut through some of
these myths by asking first of all why
did the war in the Pacific come about we
know why we had the war in the Atlantic
because Hitler declared war upon the
United States and I can say more about
that but I'm not going to the obvious
answer that I get even from my students
is the Japanese bombed Pearl Harbor and
our students are various qualities but
they always light up rightly when I
asked this question why do we fight for
the Pacific they all say because Japan
bombed Pearl Harbor then I asked why did
Japan bombed Pearl Harbor and I get this
rather glazed-over look and then I go
further and say some years ago I have
two colleagues from my University by the
way they may know whom I'm referring to
some years ago at a place call on the
campus called the Thomas More Center
which is a Center for Catholic students
I knew a Franciscan a monk named of
Thomas Lynch who had been a missionary
in Japan for some 20 years and he showed
me a photograph of a shrine to which the
Japanese Admiral Yamamoto Isoroku who
was in charge of the Pearl Harbor
operation had gone in retreat to
meditate because he believed just a few
months before the bombing of Pearl
Harbor the Pearl Harbor mission for
Japan would be suicidal which it turned
out to be and the question becomes then
why did Japan if the commander of the
operation believed that it was going to
be suicidal in the end why to Japan do
this why did they bomb Pearl Harbor I've
entitled the book empires on the Pacific
World War two and the struggle for the
mastery of Asian some of you may
recognize the subtitle I lifted it from
the title of a book written by the famed
British historian AJP Taylor called a
struggle for the mastery of Europe in
which he tried to take a non ideological
non mythical view of what had led all
the way up to the first world war and
especially what had led what had
happened as a result of Bismarck and
I've tried to take a non mythological
non ideological view of the war in the
Pacific by suggesting that in the
background and the reality was a clash
empire's I would add right now that we
Americans of course do not have an
empire other people those the French
those dirty French professor mold over
here the professor of French though
those French may have an empire but not
enough not the United States and we're
clean and pristine after all we're here
and they're there well I think the
reality is that in the background of the
the war in the Pacific World War 2 in
Asia the Pacific specific was number one
the decline and collapse of the old
Chinese Empire this was called the
Manchu Empire but I think for present
terms the Chinese Empire will do of
China had been falling apart for all
sorts of reasons having to do with
Western imperialism as well as China's
own interior in internal problems and
that gave Japan a great opportunity for
expansion
there was another Empire present also in
the 19th century and on into the 20th
century in East Asia and this was the
British Empire of the East Asian part of
the British Empire was the the far
extension of the British Empire and
perhaps it was the least important but
in East Asia Britain was declining
anyway this decline dated from the
beginning of the century with the Boxer
Rebellion when the British could not
protect their own embassies and had to
rely upon other countries all the way up
until the 1930s when the British could
not stop the Japanese from taking over
Manchuria
this was another Empire in decline
Japan was an empire on the make Japan
had begun its quest for power and wealth
soon after the landing of Admiral Perry
in the 1850s who opened Tokyo Tokyo Bay
forced Japan to accept Americans ships
and and a trade soon after that an
American Consul General named Townsend
Harris went to Japan he established the
first American Embassy there he had an
affair with the Japanese prostitute
she became pregnant he left she
committed suicide was the Opera I'm not
a metaphor of course Puccini was out to
get us as well and from that point on
the Meiji Restoration which meant Meiji
meant the means I am lighten government
Japan was absolutely determined to fend
off Western imperialism which meant
primarily British imperialism to a
lesser extent German French American and
so forth imperialism and this led to
Japan's rapid economic and military
growth and led Japan in the 20th century
to look evermore longingly upon China a
country had fallen apart into warlordism
warlordism as a term of courses in the
news right now in in Afghanistan and I
don't know much about Afghanistan but
from what I can gather for the news
there are similarities between the
warlord pattern of Afghanistan and that
of China China had fallen apart and the
Japanese were able to establish military
outposts of commercial positions in
China and during the first world war
they laid upon the Chinese what we call
the twenty-one demands which President
Woodrow Wilson forced to Japan to back
off from which would have given Japan
control over the Yangtze River Valley
that's the Great River in the center of
China and in the great commercial artery
of China after 1920s were over Japan
looked anew at China at the mainland of
Asia partly because of our own
smoot-hawley tariff that closed our
markets to Japanese goods and Manchuria
seemed to be a market and a source of
raw materials and perhaps for a
population outlet now Manchuria or the
Japanese renamed at Mantua which is
Chinese for Manchu country the Japanese
claim that this was an independent
country Manchu cook became a cause celeb
in the years to come because it seemed
to be exactly what the Chinese that I
talked with on radio was saying that
this was Manchuria today China tomorrow
and the United States the next day the
fact is that Manchuria was only
technically a Chinese province
the Chinese government was weak do not
expire do not extend to Manchuria there
was there was all sorts of violence
taking place in Manchuria and Japanese
commercial outposts were endangered the
League of Nations eventually condemned
the Japanese occupation of Manchuria in
1931 in 1932 on the ground the Japan
used force as opposed to diplomacy to
secure its interests but the league did
not deny Japanese rights to control its
own interests but the Manchurian affair
led the United States and Great Britain
to condemn Japan as an international
outlaw and I think the reason primarily
was that we too had been looking across
the Pacific empires on the Pacific we
too have been looking across the Pacific
we too had churches mission mission
missionary churches hospitals commercial
outposts and so forth and China which
the Japanese were progressively
endangering the war broke out in August
1937 the war began with an attack upon
the great city of Shanghai as well as
the Japanese incursion upon the north
the there was a terrible episode a
Japanese ship was in the Shanghai Harbor
three Chinese airplanes tried Obama they
missed they hit a hotel which is had
been rebuilt and serves wonderful dishes
especially eel the bombing uh destroyed
the front window of the hotel and there
was a man named Robert Reischauer and
those of you who read The Times the post
will be familiar with the name of Robert
Reischauer who was an economic writer
his uncle Robert Reischauer
was the son of a [ __ ] of American
missionaries in Japan he was taken a
tour group through China Japan and China
he was killed and his brother Edwin
Reischauer who became the professor of
Japanese studies at Harvard and the
American ambassador to Japan under
President Kennedy has called this the
first American casualty of World War two
we were not religious then yet the
Japanese pushed upward up the Yangtze
River and December 1937
captured the China what was then the
Chinese capital called Nanjing they
perpetrated the rape of Nanjing this was
a horrifying affair it did take place
there are photographs it did take place
a woman named iris Chung several years
ago published a book about this became
bestseller published by basic books - by
the way which is my where my book is and
she had the photographs that had
survived and it showed all sorts of
terrible atrocities one of which was the
Japanese would would round up say 50
Chinese tie them together with wire
douse them with gasoline and set them
afire I don't think this necessarily
showed that Japan the Japanese were any
more wicked than anybody else I was
reading just yesterday on the airplane
or somewhere that the the Belgians in
the Congo under King Leopold in the late
19th century carried out terrible
atrocities so I don't think this is a
racist matter as far as I can tell the
Japanese were doing this for reasons of
state carrying out the rape of Nanjing
for reasons of state name they want to
call the rest of China into submission
and what they forgot was the chapter the
Chinese have an old old and proud
tradition the Chinese name for China is
the Middle Kingdom jonghwa and the giant
the Chinese were not about to surrender
the rich more in a moment the Japanese
also bombed an American gunboat called
the pate this was in the Yangtze River
off Nanjing to take a board
diplomats journalists and others who
were caught in the Holocaust that was
taking place in Nanjing the Japanese
bombed it it was the the gunboat Pinay
which is named for an island the
Philippines was long and flat like a
Mississippi like the Delta Queen I
suppose only lower and without the
paddle wheel it had across an awning on
the top an immense American flag it was
an American vessel clearly the Japanese
bombed it it sank part of the way and
then they sent a patrol boat to sink at
the rest of the way they were trying to
clear us out of China as they were
trying to clear the British out of there
and as they were trying to conquer China
the Panna incident convinced President
Roosevelt that we had to go to war
against Japan this was a war not safe
the Chinese necessarily that's putting
things in mythical and ideological terms
it was a war of empire to stop the
expansion of Japanese Empire so that we
could preserve the influence that we did
have and the influence that we hope to
gain in in East Asia as the Chinese and
the British were declining Roosevelt
therefore put into effect a series of
embargoes stopping the sale to Japan of
such things as scrap steel I once had an
uncle made a lot of money selling scrap
steel the Japanese well he got close
down and then later in the summer of
1941 there occurred an oil embargo this
was designed to stop the Japanese
airplanes and other forms of mechanized
warfare in China and Roosevelt combined
that with the creation of a entity
called China defense supplies this was a
dummy corporation based at Delaware
intended to hire American aviators out
of the army to make them civilians but
to hire them nonetheless and to purchase
airplanes for the sake of setting this
emission to various bases in East Asia
to bomb Japan this mission began its
planning stage a year before the bombing
of Pearl Harbor and it progressed zappa
knees knew about it intelligence the
intelligence translated intelligence
sources translated show the Japanese
knew about it they believed they had to
strike us before this mission headed by
the American aviator named Claire
Chennault could strike at them once came
across a document from some of you will
know the name Tommy the cork Corcoran
who was one of the White House aides
under President Roosevelt who became the
lawyer and the chief lawyer to China
defense supplies this was the Library of
Congress so I'm not inviting the
archives here in any way shape or form
he wrote a letter saying to the board
saying that yes this is an illegal
operation but the president has
authorized it so so what is the
operation will go forward
I saw the document and archivist took it
away from me saying I wasn't supposed to
give this to you and so I wrote out what
I had seen he took that away from me too
this is over the manuscripts division of
Library of Congress and their then I amp
thereafter I repaired to the men's room
and I sat down in a stall and I wrote it
out again I stuck I stuck it in my sock
well they didn't they didn't search
stocks socks back in those days so I got
it out but this wasn't this was an
operation technically illegal that led
Japan to strike Pearl Harbor in a
pre-emptive war second myth which I did
not allude to at the brig at the
beginning the dropping of the atomic
bombs on Hiroshima and Nagasaki I'm sure
all of you are aware that the display at
the Smithsonian in the Air and Space
Museum does not have any text
surrounding it display of the Enola Gay
which dropped the bomb on Hiroshima
there's been a lot of discussion a lot
of argument about whether we should have
dropped the bombs and the argument comes
down to this that we would have saved a
million lives that figure has been much
in dispute but let's say let's say it
stands then we were saved a million
lives that would have been lost
otherwise by an invasion of Japan
therefore the dropping the bombs was
justified both morally and militarily
all the evidence I have seen indicates
very very clearly that we had destroyed
Japan already we had fire bombed Japan I
found luckily enough in a photo archive
in New York a picture which has been
used in the cover of the book which
depicts several American bombers going
presumably toward Tokyo but not
necessarily so but with Mount Fuji right
in the background in silhouette
I thought this was very indicative of
the end of the war because our far about
our far about our fire bombing leveled
approximately 100 Japanese cities their
efforts were finished and for good
measure Admiral William Halsey who was
one of the great heroes of the Pacific
War instituted a ring around Japan that
he called operations starvation Japan of
course was heavily dependent on food
imports and we were going to starve
Japan into into submission and this
operation was well into effect I have a
colleague whose wife is Japanese and
she's probably in her late 50s or so and
she remembers being hungry as a child in
World War two and this was deliberate
American policy we were squeezing Japan
and I think this the safest argument is
that we could we didn't have to invade
Japan for better or for worse
Japan was finished and we you might
wonder when to debate this point but
that's the what I think the evidence
shows and finally the end of the war
and here's another myth about World War
two that we triumphed and the war was
over and all was well in East Asia
because of our wholehearted thrashing of
the Japanese the fact is that we
proceeded to occupy Okinawa South Korea
we developed close relations with the
Nationalist government in China which
led to close relations with Taiwan and
we began to supply the French efforts to
reenter Vietnam even before the end of
the world
even before the world was or the war was
over we were establishing ourselves as
the new imperial power in East Asia
again we didn't call ourselves that but
if it walks like a duck and quacks like
a duck it probably is a duck
because we were in control of those
countries and of course there was the
occupation of Japan now there is a great
irony we fancied ourselves
thoroughly in control of the war
throughout the book I have I have
extensive passages that had to do with
our relationships with China during the
war we had the illusion we subscribed to
the illusion that China could be one of
the Four Horsemen after the war was over
in addition to the Soviet Union and
Great Britain and the United States I'm
almost tempted to say that China would
be one of the four water buffalo men or
something of the sort there was in
Washington the belief that all those
people in China this is an alux of the
old theory that the China market sooner
or later must be open and we must be
able to become wealthy by selling this
that the other to all those people all
those people must be able to produce a
strong country there's going to be so
people in Washington believes there's
going to be a strong China after the war
China is going to become democratic--
with a small d-- capitalist of course
Christianized like us there's a line
from my fair lady which says oh why
can't a woman be more like a man well
China was not and is not and never will
be like us but this was the illusion
that prevailed now there was the famous
American General Joseph Stilwell vinegar
Joe Stilwell who got it all sorts of
fights with John kai-shek the
Generalissimo of China who was holed up
in the inner reaches of China Stilwell's
point of view was that you're fighting a
war you fight the war to win it right a
reasonable point of view John kai-shek's
point of view was I'm trying to hold on
to power and therefore I hold on to
power and if hold if going in the battle
means I'm going to lose power because
the Japanese are going to defeat me I'm
not going to go into battle but the
background course for the Communists in
the remote reaches of a village called
Yunnan which is spelled Y
a n they developed a they had developed
a very efficient military force a
guerrilla force their morale was
extremely high they were fighting very
effectively against the Japanese some
American observers went to Yunnan in
late 1944 early 1945 this was called the
Dixie mission and I'm not quite sure
what it was called that because a lot of
the officers the army officers were from
the south of America or because they
were entering into rebel territory
communist territory in China but in any
case they came out with reports to the
effect that China the Chinese Communists
at least where the wave of the future
for China and the United States better
make some adjustments there there too
now another irony here is that the
reason that Chinese Communists were so
effective and were able to fight against
the Japanese was that they had to
support the people on their side this is
the first time probably in Chinese
history except maybe for a huge
rebellion in the 19th century that the
masses of the people were involved
politically most of the people lived in
a village named a village Wang where
everybody was named Wong or village CRA
by his name sia or something to sort
they may have known something about the
next village over this over the stream
or the market town a little bit beyond
but there was a little sense of Chinese
consciousness as such nationalism was
underdeveloped the Japanese invasion
caused so many refugees to flee cause
such disruptions to the self-sufficient
peasant economy that the spirit of
nationalism spread throughout China and
the Communists were there willing and
ready and able to proclaim themselves as
the leaders of this new China Mao Zedong
of course was the leader of the
Communist Party the time China Chairman
Mao he saw himself not just as a
nationalist leader he saw himself as a
new Chinese emperor the Manchus had
taken power in 1644 and before them
there was the Ming Dynasty which had
lasted for about two and a half
centuries and the founder of the Ming
- T was a peasant like Mao Mao fashioned
himself on this ancient Emperor he saw
himself as creating a new china and in
fact when the Chinese comments did take
over power formally in the October 1st
1949 Mao said China has stood up for us
the irony was that we had defeated the
Japanese Empire
we had happily said goodbye to the
British Empire and here was this new
Chinese Empire coming back into
existence this was an affront to
everything that we believed in
everything we saw ourselves as being and
therefore the United States quite
happily in an effort to contain not to
defeat because that was going to be
impossible the Japanese had been able to
defeat China but to contain this new
Chinese Empire oh yeah we called a
communist of course but it was a new
Chinese Empire to contain this new
Chinese Empire we gave assistance
tremendous assistance to the French
under provisional President shall to go
as they were trying to reestablish their
empire in Vietnam and in that sense
ladies and gentlemen I see World War 2
in Asia as the Pacific as being the seed
time for the war in Vietnam the good war
produced the bad war I think we have
some time for questions if I looked at
my watch correctly here and I hope there
I see there are several hands i I saw I
saw your hand first
questions whether FDR knew ass going to
be a question it's not mine mine is the
carpenter yet seem to thicken minimal
precautions
that's so one book and the other book
acne the impact doesn't mean the end of
the war the dropping of the bomb the
need per face to end the war because of
the USSR's entry well those are you you
phrase them as statements with their
questions and they're excellent
questions I'll be happy to do my best
here as to the first um it's possible
that MacArthur knew I have looked in the
MacArthur archives in Norfolk Virginia
and I haven't found anything there but
he was such a self glorifying son of a
[ __ ] that who knew who knows what he
knew and and if he may he may have
wanted to bring Roosevelt down from
office is possible but I would add as
I've said to similar questions that I've
received from a number of sources the
bigger picture is not whether Roosevelt
or MacArthur or somebody knew
specifically of a Japanese attack aimed
at Pearl Harbor but rather the
administration both in in Manila and in
Washington knew very well there's no
question but this was whoever knew very
well that the Japanese were planning to
move south and the Japanese were planted
to move south because they were running
out of oil hence because of our oil
embargo and they were heading for a
Samoa where there is was it is plenty of
oil the Dutch government there which was
a government in exile head under our
pressure refused to sell oil to the
Japanese the Japanese were going to take
it they knew they had to get it and our
intelligence do very well they were
preparing a fleet moving south there was
a launch in the middle of a called the
Lanikai the captain was named kemp Tolly
he's written a book about this a tol le
why
he received orders to take the launch
out into the South China Sea in a
position directly in front of the
oncoming Japanese fleet he believes he
was being sacrificed
well then Pearl Harbor came along and he
was able to get back to Manila Bay but
Roosevelt was trying to create an
incident that would justify our entry
into the war against Japan and whether
this incident was at Pearl Harbor or the
Philippines I don't think he cared he
said three times - twice to Churchill
and once the Lord Halifax the British
ambassador that I would I'm going to
provoke a war now you can make say maybe
he was lying maybe he was he said a lot
of things a lot of people but this is
that this is documented but he was
trying to provoke a war as far as the
Soviet Union entering into the Far East
Roosevelt and Stalin at the Yalta
Conference of early 1945 cut a deal
I said beginning rather sarcastically
we're not an empire and of course we
don't enter into such things as spheres
of influence and the balances of power
and buffer zones and all that that's
what those Europeans do well it was a
trade Roosevelt allowed Stalin to get
the old Tsarist territories extended all
with a lot of us talking to that in
Manchuria in exchange for a Soviet
recognition not other communists but of
the Nationalists who are our our proxies
or our supporters our allies whatever
term we should use the Soviet Union
acceded thus to the control of China of
an American ally thus to American
influence in China itself in return for
our acknowledging Soviet influence and
power in classic a capitalist Russia
okay I see I think I saw your head next
to the corner of my eye yes please now
viewed situation in Afghanistan the
situation with the provinces sinigang
the Islamic extremists uh I'm also
wondering you are given what we've heard
about the Chinese reaction to 9/11 the
fact that Charles even apparently looks
at these fit the videotapes of what
happened and floats on and talks about
American arrogance they're being humble
this I'll answer that question in two
ways there's an old expression which I
think comes from the French originally
but it's used in many contexts which is
that the enemy of my enemy is my friend
and since both we and the Chinese have
defined the Muslim world as our enemy
now and China has a serious problem with
the Muslim ethnic minorities in the far
reaches of the room Qi and near the Gobi
Desert and so forth we have an
overlapping interest in what controlling
containing the power of the Islamic
world on the other hand there's very
little question and this takes us back
to the Chinese airplane that knocked
down the American spy plane time is
passing isn't it was about a year and a
half ago or so and the Chinese pilot by
the way is named Wang Wei that
mr. that episode I think illustrates the
fact that other Chinese still see us as
the major Imperial threat and although
they need us for trade purposes they
don't trust us at all
when we lived in China need to get too
personal here but I think it works
my wife offered my assistant was known
as a barbarian handler or a spy he's now
the head of the American Canadian
section of the Chinese Academy of Social
Sciences and I think you can figure out
what that means
that's KGB in China she offered him a
piece of candy for as the boy was about
1 years old one year old at the time and
he rejected it saying I know your tricks
this fella is hooked into the
establishment his father was a major
professor of English at Beijing
University and this fellow was a scholar
Oxford and then later in Berkeley he's
all hooked in he's wired and I think he
was establishing as might be especially
expressing a view that I won't say
everyone subscribed to in China hardly
but it's it's it's pretty close to the
official line and this is spaciousness
of us keeps arising I think many Chinese
really would love to come to America and
I study English but when we were there I
kept getting the question why did you do
it to us referring to what the English
did to the opium wars not I was involved
but why did you do it to us our problems
you have caused our problems was the
question
and why did you do that I got that
constantly I hope that satisfies your
question of these partly I saw your hand
up with 100 of Roosevelt and wanted to
go to war against Japan sir
reason to do it years earlier was there
a conscious effort to delay war in the
Far East until the American people were
ready for more on in the European
theater as well to orchestrate the
timing so that for example did you know
that after that Hitler would declare war
on the United States and that lead to
delay or against Japan until such time
as we could have both wars both theaters
worst both theatres simultaneously I
will complicate that by saying that we
were already bored with Germany
by the summer of 1941 it was the
undeclared war in the Atlantic and there
was a document that I found once in the
Washington Navy Yard from January 1941
it was the so called ABC agreement
American Britain Canada agreement and it
was a pledge by the United States to
launch economic warfare which meant
bombing German ships factories trains
and so forth as distinguished from other
kinds of warfare very soon after we had
seized control of the middle of the
Atlantic so I will complicate that by
saying that we are already almost a year
before Pearl Harbor were at war with
Germany I think there was probably a
desire to on Roosevelt part to make sure
the American people were ready for war
against Japan although another
complication is that American
isolationism was aimed primarily toward
Europe not toward the Far East it was
Germany that we didn't want if people
didn't want to find Japan was a
different story I think the major reason
that it took four years for us to be at
war with Japan after the Panay incident
was that we simply weren't prepared for
a major war the in in my book I have a
picture a photograph of Henry Kaiser who
was the California industrialist who by
the end of 1942 was Purdue or middle to
end of 1942 was producing one Liberty
ship these the troop ships one-a-day
what we weren't ready yet to do that
I don't think we had the technology to
do it and their Congress wasn't ready to
spend the money I think the lack of
preparedness is explained as much as any
kind of strategic thinking 25 yeah well
it's all easier oh yeah you have to
forego some Dirty Bird comparison
between the American Empire I recognized
today is a number of corporate edges and
you've heard the term the great game or
the new great game and it's being
practiced in some way well what
similarities do you see there between
moral resources and the settling
pre-roll and the historical reasons we
have long acknowledged or many many
people have long acknowledged that we
have an informal economic Empire that's
what I think you're talking about when
you talk about corporate presence of
corporate presence overseas but I would
remind you that we have military bases
in many parts of East Asia and we have
military bases in Europe the old NATO
bases I would remind you that NATO has
expanded that we have we now have a
presence that is going to be with us for
many years to come in the Balkans and
now we are going to have a presence in
Afghanistan and surrounding areas of
Pakistan and the like for an indefinite
period III would define an empire in
part as being the presence of one's
military forces overseas keeping order
which is in large part with the British
we're doing not attacking people but at
least in their own eyes keeping order I
think it's also clear that our political
influence is enormous is enormous
years ago Henry Kissinger talked about
getting our claws into the Soviet Union
well we have our claws into Russia
and Eastern Europe economically and I
think politically okay I but I saw um
he's in he or interpret the
psychological religious and spiritual
effect of the unconditional surrender by
Japan and the Emperor being forced to
deny his divinity do you think the
terrorist interpretation of Islam I mean
can that be fought in a similar way or
can they can that belief system be
attacked in a similar fashion I don't
have the faintest idea uh but as a
professor I will have to express myself
anyway but yeah the D deification of the
Emperor of Japan was clearly part of our
effort to turn Japan into an American
colony they can have the emperor as a
constitutional monarch as long as they
did our bidding as long as they accepted
our imposed Constitution which on paper
at least turned Japan into
american-style democracy I think that's
the basic meaning of the occupation of
Japan as far as Islam goes all I can say
is that I think it's very clear I didn't
say this with response to the earlier
question I think it's very clear that
the America the United States has an
imperial presence in the Middle East as
well I don't know how I do not know how
else to interpret our well aside from
our support for is for Israel a long
time ago in 1975 or so somebody called
Millis Ignotus is Latin for the unknown
soldier it may have been Henry Kissinger
he was defined as an academic with ties
to the defense in the State Department I
wrote an article in Harper's or Atlantic
about the Persian Gulf this was after
the Arab oil embargo and he said the
article said let's take the Gulf well
the golf is ours ladies and gentlemen
dr. Robert actually before everyone goes
I'd like to present dr. Thompson with a
gift I've decided that in year 2002 it
just seems fitting to present seventy a
copy of a record that we have the
National Archives that may in some way
relate to this topic it's a bit of a
stretch but here goes
what I have here is an exact life-sized
black-and-white copy what hole the size
of the Thompson submachine gun you get
this upside down
this is a copy direct iPhones this is a
copy in 156 records of the office of the
chief of ordnance and we have several
thousand engineering and architectural
drawings in the National Archives this
is a copy of the Thompson submachine gun
the 45 caliber the 1928 day one version
please accept this and I well not very
much for hi thank you very much I'll
take credit for it
when we all adjourn to the back of the
room we'll have our book signing now
thank you
Robert Thompson is a professor of
history at the University of South
Carolina he's the author of a time for
war FDR and the path to Pearl Harbor the
missiles of October of the Declassified
story of John F Kennedy in the Cuban
Missile Crisis and his latest Empires on
the Pacific it's published by basic
books if you'd like to find out more you
can visit their website basic books calm